so
so here here's your yield yeah it's very
much but
we're half the size it doesn't have to
be big it's right here
long drop that was it oh there you go
and then then i find the connection
it's not that i'm doing his arm here and
then
i'm bringing his i brought his head here
and the wrist's not important now
that's your goal you do it you
boom there all right and i
make sure you're tight okay so i have a
little bit
whoa got it whoa
yields head got it
in my body
so i'm not just turning then i never
cleared the line
it's very subtle boom there to keep that
ski miss
so you picture the ski well i'm on the
outside of the ski
okay and then not on his fingers
[Music]
in
so very small internal flexion pool
garnet
boom body pops
in
home
so i'm not going to move like this just
small
deviations reach up
[Music]
so small boom that was it
small hole
hand-to-head adhesions
[Music]
oh come on
hey